question number two
i ask god to help me recover completely
from an eating disorder
and to help me find my place in this
world
i fall sometimes does that mean that i
am not as close to jesus as i think i am
people who are sincere in their
relationship with christ they can fall
notice i said they can fall there's
nothing in the bible that says you have
to fall
when you've come to christ you've been
converted you do not have to fall
the bible says in first john chapter 2
verse 1 my little children these things
write i unto you that he sin not and if
any man's sin we have an advocate with
the father christ jesus the righteous
and he is the propitiation for our sins
and not for ours only but also for the
sins of the whole world
god has made provision if we sin
never think you have to sin always think
jesus by your grace i do not have to sin
but if you fall
get up quickly
repent
confess
tell god you're sorry and tell him from
your heart and ask him to give you the
power to move on every time we sin in
the moment we sin it is because at that
time we have let go of christ
did you hear me
at the moment we sin is when we let go
of christ
we release the hold of faith and we sin
you can't sin when you're holding on to
christ with all your heart you just
can't do it
question